like you seem to have like a very wide
one thing I've always liked your content
is that you've never really focused on
one thing you've always had like a wide
like intro I don't even know what your
tastes are
like sometimes I try to like narrow down
your tastes and I look at like some of
the stuff that you know jaunders is like
kind of Series where he likes things
I've liked in summer or winter and I'm
like this has no [__] correlation at
all it's this random assault machine
yeah do you do you have a certain like
taste or interest that you can boil it
down to or is it just kind of like no no
like I like
things that I think are interesting but
I I like being that way as well yeah you
know because like I do feel like there
is correlations between things like I've
learned a lot about storytelling through
like professional wrestling you know
I've learned a lot about like I guess
how to structure things from martial
arts and you can take a lot of different
things from all different things but uh
yeah I think it's it's one of the ways
my channel is kind of weird and it's
it's one of the ways that I should
probably never have survived on YouTube
you know what I mean
I don't agree with that I think I think
people just like having a consistent
voice that they can come back sure yeah
yeah here like a delivery on something
it doesn't always have to be the same
thing I think people just like having
someone inform them because I I like
just learning about stuff that I do not
care about yeah and I think there's as
well like with your channel there's
always that like element of surprise of
like okay
on Garfield from anywhere else you know
what I mean yeah like what's the next
topic going to be and then when they see
something that they just weren't
expecting or they're like well I mean
John made it and it's [__] two hours
long it must be interesting right and
and that's how people get hooked you
know yeah we had this conversation a few
weeks ago on the podcast about martial
arts movies so I thought I asked you
about this uh so like I feel that there
were like way more kind of like The
Prestige of like especially Hong Kong
martial arts film existed back in the
day and I feel like they've kind of
fallen off and we had this theory that
UFC kind of maybe ruined the Mystique of
like martial arts do you think there's
like credit oh I would say there's
definitely there's definitely an element
to that like I think UFC and it was
really interesting because professional
wrestling had to deal with this problem
as well because like oh that's what I'm
fight actually looks like and it's not
beautiful and it's not pretty and 80 of
it 80 of it is two sweaty guys rolling
you know
um and so like yeah I absolutely think
there's something to that but I also
would say in that there is the capacity
for martial arts movies to become the
next thing and they haven't yet right
but like I do think you see it peek
through with stuff like the raid or John
Wick 4 was a [__] incredible movie
was that equilibrium yeah yeah yeah that
was a great film that was fun that was
really important
how do you feel like martial art film
could evolve into like the modern era
because I think it's it's not just UFC
like sometimes I just get recommended of
like you know videos where it's just
like martial artists tries to defend
against like a knife attack and like
showing like the reality of how many
times they would actually get hit and
then you realize there are just some
things that you just can't defend
against so like in a weird way I think
that actually like social media has
become a huge part of martial arts
because you get like a lot of amateur
Fighters now who have like you know they
they're posting their tick tocks and
their daily routines and all that kind
of stuff yeah I'd love to see a movie
kind of based around that but like it's
it's a weird one as well I also think
like with all the [__] that's happening
with like influencer boxing that has
kind of become The Narrative of modern
martial arts you know yeah that's true I
mean okay we've done enough influence
books I want to see more influence of
wrestling now though
I think influence wrestling is very hard
I think wrestling is just super
technical yeah I mean yeah it is even
just trying it for like one hour it was
like try not to hurt yourself challenge
difficult first back bump and you're
like this is what these guys go through
yeah they told me it was soft for them
yeah I was like this is not soft I I
winded myself when I fell and I was like
but you would know that it would just be
a treasure Trove of memes just like fun
like Mr Beast coming in with the
people's elbows
like you've done wrestling training
before what goes into that so like it's
it it is you are working with another
person doing all these like high impact
moves but the thing that like scared me
was the idea I didn't want to [__] up
and hurt the other person right you know
that to me became way scarier than
fighting another person you know because
I was like oh [__] like I don't want to
be responsible for this person's injury
but it's like it's a lot of stuff like
when people get up it's like you always
grab the person's left hand so you have
to you have to be very conscious of like
when I get up my left hand has to be
here and I have to be like telegraphing
this so they know to do that I never got
far enough with it to like speak on it
with any kind of authority so I don't
want to but yeah like it's like Conor
was saying it's this massively technical
thing right because I've noticed that
I've seen some of your posts and you've
done some wrestling events right or when
you come to England you've got like some
like evil Persona yeah yeah
Leslie bestington yeah
um I work with a company called Coliseum
wrestling and um it's fun dude like it
is you look like you're having the time
I I really am like the thing is like you
can like actually getting to piss off
the crowd especially kids because kids
kids can't they like you know the way
kids have the thing where they can't
tell what's real and what is it you can
piss them off so much and they will look
at you with the purest hatred you've
ever seen But like I'd go I'd like I go
up to their parents and I'll be like um
I'm gonna have to ask you to calm your
child down you know
everyone's but um it's so fun as well
because like I got to do a meet and
greet the last time and so I was like
okay what would Leslie bestington do for
a meet and greet so I wrote uh
autographs 400 pounds and I just put it
there and so like these kids came up to
the table and like um I was like hey
what's your name what's your name and I
signed three autographs and I looked at
the dad and I was like 1200 pounds
please
and uh like it it's just it's it's a lot
of fun yeah yeah so what is the
character that you play just kind of
like so if you've seen my influencer
video it's the guy I do at the start of
that Leslie best thing yeah social media
and his whole thing is that he doesn't
understand professional wrestling he
thinks he thinks it's silly so the first
time I ever did it
um I basically came out and I was like I
don't really get wrestling I'm more a
boxing man myself and I respect all the
greats Jake Paul Logan the crowd melted
down they got so mad and I was like I
got them I got them
oh wow look at that oh I'm so sick that
looks so fun new followers to you people
have let me let me guess uh six this is
me guessing their followers
definitely definitely one what have you
done uh buddy you you did what you
always do nothing
that's so dark oh that's great it's it's
fun did this come from like how did this
start does this come from like the
social media video or did you yeah I
just done that and they got in contact
with me and were like do you want to do
some something and I was like yes I do
and so yeah that's so cool yeah yeah
it's it's so interesting when you see
YouTube's kind of just go into a whole
nother realm but obviously you have
history in it but it's kind of cool
seeing it and then seeing you do it yeah
it's been it's been fun it's it's
definitely interesting going into like a
wrestling locker room and you kind of
think you're in shape until like you go
in you're like oh I'm like a a little
boy
yes they are very funny I've done some
wrestling videos as well right uh yeah I
did a video with takeshore who's like
insane now oh yeah yeah he's he's done
so well it's so funny because I when I
met up with him he was just casually
telling me about how he's gonna go to
America for a few months and I was like
oh cool cool cool cool I didn't think
anything of it but he was so funny and
so good on camera when I was working
with him uh and then yeah short shortly
after I just occasionally every every
now and then I get tweets being like
yeah she's crushing it yeah yeah like
he's not quite Main Event level yet but
he's like getting there it's like insane
your video was a little more interesting
than my experience because I did it for
Rockies video where she got beat up
right yeah
I put on a Luchador mask and uh ladybird
clothesline me and uh that was not fun
yeah I I have said this so many times
but I didn't understand that they
actually hit each other uh and so that
when they slapped me with the chalk oh
my chop was just like slapping someone's
chest yeah it's a bit different but
they're hitting your chest and they do
it for real and I didn't realize this
because in American ones they do do this
but in Japan they love doing this
I have a thing called Strong Style which
just means we're going to actually
tradition and
um you know for the video I really
wanted to even though I have like a
blood condition I I was like I don't
tell them now because I don't want them
to worry and I knew I'd be fine I was
like I actually wanted to get in I
wanted them to like kind of just do it
on me so I was like well [__] it I I
should try and good experience I also
feel like if you're gonna [__] do a
video somewhere you should [__] get
involved like you should actually like
try and do it for as much as you can so
I when I used to train in wrestling I
like got in trouble because one of the
people there she was like like a 14 year
old girl yeah and like we were doing
like the chop Circle which just means
like you have to chop the person next to
you yeah and I was like
[Music]
even jumping it's literally just falling
on your back yeah and it's still really
[__] hurt but Blossom they were so
good they really like had me like that
was terrible wow you know I tried my
best yeah but they yeah they really
[__] put me to work it was really fun
I'll never forget it yeah so someone who
only knows wrestling through your videos
what's like the difference between like
different countries and different
leagues uh of wrestling oh I mean like
there's a lot of different types um
American tends to be like well now you
have like WWE and aw and like but it
tends to be like a little more showy a
little more like thinking about people
who aren't into wrestling like a lot of
the times WWE will try and keep its
matches quite kind of short and snappy
aew is a bit more for hardcore wrestling
Japanese wrestling is like tends to be
there's not a lot of like gimmicks or
like story lines in Japanese wrestling
other than these two men want to be
better than each other it's kind of been
that like there is exceptions to that
but it's like that is actually to me the
most compelling wrestling just because
it is how long is uh because how long is
a normal wrestling match then for like
WWE and aw what's like average I'd say
anywhere between seven and 15 minutes
see I I I was watching a 15-minute fight
and I felt like that was very long I
felt like that was just like so what I'd
say it's like an episode like of
anything yeah if it's good it'll fly by
you sure right right what do you
recommend to get someone into wrestling
then where where does where do you
recommend someone would start watch my
videos
I actually hate saying that but my
answer is like watch my videos and if
you see a wrestler you like in those
videos go track down more of their
matches and watch their stuff because
like wrestling at the end they it's a
story about characters and it's a story
about like there long-term Journey over
many years and how that like combines
with their real life and that's
genuinely the advice I give yeah because
one thing I always one thing I found
interesting that you mentioned was like
the like kind of like the separation of
when someone's playing a character and
when someone is like how do you balance
like the character you're playing and
the person that the wrestler actually is
which is a really interesting part part
of the culture of that where you know
with would you say that
you know would you say that wrestling is
is on the same level as a fictional
story or does part of the appeal come
from not knowing where the separation is
I mean like
if you're really into wrestling the
people who really really love it you are
paying attention to the fiction and the
reality right but the problem like
what's so interesting about it is like
where one starts when you can never
[__] tell right you know and like you
have people who think like everything's
a work we're being set up you know but
then it's like no I think this dude
actually just sucks you know
like it but like that's what's kind of
fascinating about it you know yeah yeah
did you when since you have been
interesting for a long time did you ever
have like you know in school or
something where it's just like oh you
know wrestling's fake no it's fake I
remember like going on a walk with my
Dad yeah and being like
that is wrestling fake
and he just goes odd is John yeah
and I remember just pausing and going
no I don't think it is
why because I used to be into it when I
was a kid and I think that's when I kind
of realized it was fake I kind of felt
like betrayed almost as a kid yeah
because I was so into it it's like
finding out Santa's not really yeah oh
[__] I think it's worse
it just it felt so real and then I
realized as I got older now I've only
really come to appreciate this in the
past year or two is that no it's I mean
from the physical aspect alone it's so
impressive and The Fleets that they're
pulling off but like and then the
stories as well yeah it's like okay
you're little and you're watching it
it's like okay Sean Michaels and Bret
Hart hate each other and they're gonna
fight yeah and then you learn it's not
real and you're like oh okay Shawn
Michaels and Bret Hart are working
together to put on what is basically a
very painful choreographed dance okay
yeah but then you get to layer three and
it's like no Sean Michaels and Bret Hart
do hate each other and they have to work
together to put on this choreographed
dance that is wrestling you know like
that's what's [__] interesting about
it like I'm not gonna get into it look
up the Montreal screw job most insane
thing to ever happen crazy
what I want to know are you going to
tell me about it okay give us
so basically I'm sorry to everyone who
likes wrestling has heard this a million
times Bret Hart is the champion he's
about to leave the company and he's
refusing to lose to Sean Michaels he's
like I'm not going to do this because I
[__] hate this guy so much they have
to put on this Main Event show together
and so they arrange the whole match Bret
Hart's gonna win or it's gonna be a draw
or something and there's going to be a
bit where Shawn Michaels puts Bret Hart
in his own finishing move the
Sharpshooter and to Bret Hart he's going
to reverse it and tap Sean Michaels out
and that's going to be the end of the
match
however before that happens they ring
the bell to make it look like Bret Hart
Tapped Out
oh okay and you can see he's like what
the [__] that wasn't how this is meant
to go he spits on the owner of the
company it's this giant like disgrace
and like basically backstage goes insane
and it's it's just this weird like
blending of reality and like you know so
there's people who would be like this
that was all that was all set up I don't
think it was
that's that that's pretty cool yeah
that's really [__] interesting to
hear more about it in my video
villains of wrestling I don't know if I
even said the right videos
I think so yeah yeah